طب جانبه قال روبرت وود نائب المندوبه
الامريكيه في مجلس الامن ان رئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يصعد سلوك روسيا الخطير
والمزعزع للاستقرار من خلال التهديد بنشر
الاسلحه النوويه في بيلاروسيا حسب تعبير
الرياضي
الحقيقه هي ان الكريملين لا يريد ان تمتلك
اوكرانيا القدره على الدفاع عن نفسها ضد
الدبابات الروسيه دعونا نقول انه لن يكون
من الضروري امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
الدفاعيه اذا لم تكن روسيا قد سن تغزو
واسع النطاق على اوكرانيا اعلان الرئيس
بوتين في الخامس والعشرين من مارس الذي
اشار فيه الى ان نيته نجري اسلحه نوويه في
بيلاروسيا لا يتعلق بتقاسم الاعباء
النوويه لا توجد اسباب موثوقه تتعلق
بالدفاع لروسيا لوضع اسلحه نوويه في
بيلاروسيا